Some anomalies kill for fun, others for food,
others because they simply have no choice. On
the other side of the coin, some want nothing
more than to spread love, joy, and happiness.
But it’s rare that you see an anomaly
that has genuinely pure intentions,
but whose attempts to do good often turn deadly.
One such figure, and the subject of today’s tale,
is SCP-049 - The Plague Doctor.
If you’re at all familiar with SCP Foundation,
then you will have likely heard of the infamous
Plague Doctor. For those of you who haven’t,
here’s a bit of context for SCP-049.
He appears exactly as you’d expect a
plague doctor from the late medieval period
or renaissance periods. A tall figure,
shrouded in long black robes, a hood over his head
with only a venetian beaked mask protruding from
underneath. These aren’t just a fashion statement
either, the SCP Foundation discovered that
these are all part of SCP-049’s physical body,
sharing a similar structure to muscle and bone.
The Plague Doctor’s primary goal is to find those
he considers to be infected with something he
refers to as The Pestilence. If he ever senses
this affliction, he will attempt to make direct
skin contact with the person carrying it.
Why? Because SCP-049’s touch is lethal,
killing anyone he comes into contact with.
You might think that’s all the Plague Doctor does,
goes from person to person, killing them with his
deadly touch, but you would be wrong. Once he’s
killed a victim, SCP-049 then begins performing a
crude, outdated form of surgery on their corpse.
Using equipment he produces from his mysterious
and apparently bottomless magical medical satchel,
he injects a number of unknown chemicals into
the corpse, which brings them back to life and
turns them into an instance of SCP-049-2; or
in other words, a vicious, mindless zombie.
At present, SCP-049 is kept secure in a
holding cell by the Foundation, under watch
by surveillance cameras for twenty-four hours a
day. And that is where our story begins. The tale
of a deadly, dangerous doctor, and his days spent
in captivity. Locked away in a cage, contained by
the SCP Foundation, there he sits, alone. It is a
tale known only by the simple title: “Going Home.”
It begins with the Plague Doctor, left alone in
his cell. He had been there for such a long time
that he’d forgotten exactly how long. But there he
sat, taunted by the sensation of pestilence around
him. It was a small, almost undetectable feeling,
but it reeked of decay and disease, hanging
in the very air particles of SCP-049’s cell.
Although they had long since stopped the practice,
the SCP Foundation used to send its doctors and
researchers into 049’s cell, bringing him cadavers
as test subjects. The Plague Doctor would use
these specimens to hone his craft, perfecting
his method of transforming the dead into instances
of SCP-049-2. But, of course, the doctors working
for the Foundation weren’t exactly free of disease
themselves and they too often needed to be cured
by his touch, and soon they stopped visiting
SCP-049 in person, leaving him alone in his cell.
Even these so-called people of science
feared the true cure, it seemed.
They would talk to the Plague Doctor via
an intercom system, interviewing him and
asking questions about what he did or how
he felt. One question stood out to SCP-049:
the Foundation researchers had asked him if he
had any regrets for what he had done to people.
The Plague Doctor thought it foolish to even ask.
And then, even the questions coming through the
intercom stopped after a while. For a
time, SCP-049 was happy in his cell,
left alone with his thoughts, safe from the
diseases of the outside world. The Plague Doctor
was at peace for a change, resting in comfort.
Until the familiar smell of pestilence returned.
The presence of disease drove him to attempt
an escape. Producing his medical implements
from the bag he kept concealed in his robes,
SCP-049 tried to pry open the door to his cell.
He wasn’t sure how long it took, the passage of
time had long since stopped registering to him.
But eventually, he had it open, just
enough so that he could pass through,
out into the corridor beyond the chamber he
had been held in. There was no one else around,
no doctors or researchers or Foundation security
personnel. No one to stop the Plague Doctor from
following the stench of the disease that had
driven him to find a way out of containment.
Navigating through the hallways of the Foundation
facility, SCP-049 tracked the source of the
disease to a locker. With little trouble,
he opened it, finding a metallic box within.
As he studied the container, his fingers found the
button that opened it. It hissed as the gases kept
the inside of the box mixed with the air. The cold
vapor hit the Plague Doctor in the face, catching
him by surprise and making him drop the box.
Reasserting himself, the Plague Doctor bent
over and picked up the contents of the
refrigerated container: a single mosquito.
It wasn’t the insect itself that had drawn
SCP-049 out of his cell. True, mosquitos
are known to spread diseases like malaria, but it
was what was inside this mosquito that the Doctor
wanted to eradicate. Its blood sac was full,
swollen with dark fluid that SCP-049 knew to be
infected. Using the metal box as an improvised
operating table, he produced his bag of medical
implements, and the doctor began to operate.
He retrieved a syringe from his bag, and a
vial filled with thick, black liquid. Half filling
the syringe with the liquid, he plunged the needle
into the mosquito, and extracted the blood that
the insect was carrying. The infected bodily fluid
mixed with the medicine in the doctor’s syringe,
leaving the bug as little more than a dry husk.
The Plague Doctor watched as the two substances
mixed together, before stabbing it back into
the mosquito, filling the creature with the
combination of both liquids. He refused to leave
any trace of pestilence in the insect’s body.
The mosquito twitched itself back to life,
looking around until it saw SCP-049 observing it.
“Who’s there?” it asked. “Where is Merle?”
“There is no one here but me, and you,” the
doctor explained. “You are in a prison. Though,
the wardens, it seems, have left.”
“A prison?” the insect responded,
“Oh god! I’m at Site 19!”
Naturally, it seemed rather
strange for a mosquito to be able to talk, let
alone know about the highly classified Site 19.
But, as is always the case in the SCP Foundation,
the strange always has an anomalous explanation.
You see, this mosquito was not like any other.
For one, she even had a name; it was Leslie.
As it turned out, Leslie was a part of an SCP,
one of the Foundation’s own creation: SCP-3774.
These were a genetically and cybernetically
enhanced species of mosquito. Why would the
Foundation spend time and resources creating
something like this? Originally, they were
designed as an undetectable, covert way of keeping
tabs on Persons of Interest to the SCP Foundation.
The Plague Doctor thought it odd that, after
having spent so much time imprisoned there, that
he should finally learn the name of Site 19 from
a mosquito, of all things. Leslie seemed to be
in a state of panic, however, urgently insisting
that she had to get back to someone named Merle.
SCP-049 had no clue what she meant, he’d never
encountered anyone that went by that name,
and had no idea where to even begin looking.
“I know where he lives, I can find it,”
the mosquito insisted. “I just… I don’t
know how I could ever get out of here.”
She was wary of the creature she found herself
talking to. Despite being a genetically engineered
insect, Leslie was, for all intents and purposes,
an agent of the SCP Foundation. And now, she was
currently conversing with an anomaly that she knew
nothing about. But he wasn’t trying to harm her,
in fact, whatever the Plague Doctor
had done seemed to have revived her.
“I have gotten myself this far, and now that I
have, I have no further reason to stay here.”
The doctor announced, holding a
hand out for Leslie to fly up to.
“Then… then you’ll help me get out of here?” she
asked, readying her wings and landing in his palm.
“I will,” SCP-049 agreed.
The pair introduced themselves properly,
Leslie giving SCP-049 her name while he just
instructed her to call him “doctor”, before they
set out together. After almost a week of traveling
on foot through rugged terrain and harsh winds,
the Plague Doctor and his insect companion
had yet to encounter another living soul.
Thick, dark clouds hung in the sky above them,
and Leslie soon found it hard to remember what
the sun looked like. She feared that
she might even forget Merle’s face.
“We’re close.” she said. “Just
a few more miles, and then…”
“And then we will arrive,”
SCP-049 finished her sentence.
“Tell me, doctor, why did you come all this way
with me?” Leslie the mosquito asked, “You could
have left when we got out, gone your own way.”
In response he gave one simple sentence:
“Merely because I wanted to.”
Finally, the intrepid pair arrived at
a house once belonging to Merle. It was abandoned,
ramshackle, in a total state of disrepair. Decades
had passed since anyone had set foot in the place.
The living room that had once been so familiar
to Leslie had now been transformed into a
barren, empty space. The sight of it made
her so distraught with sadness that she would
have been sick, if mosquitoes could be sick.
Merle, whoever he was or had
been, was now nowhere to be found.
One of Leslie’s cybernetic enhancements was
an internal positioning system, giving her all
sorts of data and readouts, including a clock.
It told her just how long she’d been away for.
“I’ve been dead for two hundred years?”
the mosquito cried in the palm of the
doctor’s hand. “Then… then Merle is…
is dead. Everyone… everyone is dead.”
She kept repeating it to herself, over and over as
if she was trying to convince herself of what had
happened. Eventually, the words lost all meaning.
As he held Leslie in his hands, perhaps the Plague
Doctor felt sorry for the mosquito. After all,
the Plague Doctor had always had a respectful,
polite personality despite his frightening
exterior. He had always believed that he’d acted
in service of the greater good, trying to cure the
world of pestilence, to bring the end of disease.
He only ever killed because, to him, it was in
his victim’s best interest for him to perform his
procedures. To his captors at the SCP Foundation,
the doctor had been courteous and co-operative,
and he acted the same towards his fellow
SCPs. Not just Leslie, but even the sort
of anomalies with nothing but hatred in their
hearts. The doctor saw them as just further
victims of the pestilence, in need of curing.
SCP-049 sat in silence for a while with his
mosquito friend, letting her mourn the loss
of Merle and everything she had ever known.
“Where will you go now?” he asked.
Still in tears, barely able to speak
through her sobs, Leslie decided that she wanted
to stay where she was. The insect wanted to live
where Merle had lived, in a desperate attempt to
recapture the world that she once knew. Sitting
in the Plague Doctor’s gloved hand, still sobbing
even though she had run out of tears, Leslie said:
“Any minute… any minute Merle
will come through the door.”
The Plague Doctor held his tiny companion
where she was, while she grieved.
“Then I will wait for him,”
he told her, “here with you.”
Now go check out “SCP-049 - the Plague Doctor
Captured” and “SCP-049 - What Actually is the
Pestilence? The Plague Doctor Questions and
Theories” for more on this enigmatic medicine man!